a hot day at kauffman stadium and the
season finale
between the minnesota twins and the
kansas city royals that means that those
teams will not play each other again
next weekend
as they have for each of the last three
and they'll see young royal southpaw
chris bubich today and he led the entire
minor leagues and strikeouts last year
he has 19 and 19 and a third in the
first four starts of his major league
career two down and now it will be cino
who has a six game hitting streak
left center field that's to the gap with
two outs kepler leaving with the crack
of the bat he's heading to third he's
being waved home here's the throw
monday's throw not in time and sono
delivers again an rbi double and it's
one to nothing but he has been red-hot
hitting over four right at 400 over the
last five ball games a lot of extra base
hits
and now eddie rosario
it would be the second highest total
there's a proud ball pace in left field
cenote being waved around third and
he'll score with rosario
grounding an rbi single to left field
good piece of hitting right there looked
like a breaking ball eddie stayed back
nicely and with the ship put on just
found that hole between third and short
matt whistler whistler 27 years old
making his second
start of the season facing mirrorfield
merrifield drops one into left field so
the royals have a good start to the
bottom of the first inning
that's base hit number 34 for merrifield
this year yeah now that's what we're
talking about mirrorfield a threat to
steal with lopez at the plate
papa
and vargas going out this is trouble oh
what a catch by vargas
with his back to the infield in a full
sprint
one away what a great defensive play
right there by vargas so two outs and
here is franco one two count and here's
the pitch and that is strike three
called inside corner knee high
on a breaking ball that came back down
and in and franco shakes his head we've
seen that a lot this weekend first start
for starling in this series former first
round pick or the o2 pitch a swing and a
miss strike three
and whistler does it again a one two
three second likely done
back-to-back outings two scoreless
innings against the wolves and now
cracked a double to left center field to
drive in the first run of the game
and a base hit to left right off the end
of the bat but still dropped it into
left for a
the average climbing
in big chunks with every game but now
rosario
now a bunt and a beauty and rosario will
get a bunt single to fill them up i
don't know that i've ever seen eddie
rosario get a bunt single but he got it
by the pitcher and they're loaded up
here's gonzalez lined to left to end the
first inning now the base has loaded
nobody out and he drills one fair into
the corner
crews will score ceno behind him rosario
to third on a two-run double by marwin
gonzalez this is what we saw so often
last year in ambush second time through
the batting order here's the biggest out
of the game for the twins so far here
this afternoon
rip down the line in comes valoria in
comes dozier and the royals have cut the
lead in half
the
strength of jorge solaire back to back
doubles solaire got a big hit
so here's michael franco three and two
with two down
and he got him on the inside corner
franco is called out again the royals
with a couple of two out doubles and
they've cut the twins lead in half
here we got our hot guy and that is
miguel sano
pulled to third franco has it second one
first base
two
that's an ending ending double play oh
wow put a star on that
they need to get jk keep it at four to
two
he struck him out
great job by greg holland comes in with
two on nobody out gets the double play
then the strikeout
the batter is max kepler who is over two
with a walk and a run scored
oh dude wow great job of pitching by far
the best of any worker today fantastic
two down and now valoria
and here it is he's trying to miss
came right after him 84. that slider and
they picked up the strikeout now vargas
up with runners second and third
little roller this is gonna be tough
lopez shovels got him nice play by nicky
michael bronco coming up
and that ball is smoked and it knocks
off the glove of gonzalez rolls into
shallow left dozier will score solaire
goes to third and the royals are within
one gonzalez will tell you that was my
bad i bet he looks like he might have
caught that
now cruz it's working
uh oh oh that's right
you got him nelson cruz
on a 99
mile an hour fastball
just hit his sixth home run against the
royals this year he
is
a
monster
so it'll be up to michael franco
how about that
base hit by franco dozier's going to
score and the royals are within one
good at banned by michael frankel
it'll be the lefty lefty matchup rogers
versus alex gordon
fly ball left field hit right at rosario
and the twins take two of three in
kansas city